everybody welcome to today's webinar
this is beautiful from the NCBI this is
a webinar on the human population
genetic variation data at NCBI lawn fawn
is going to be our presenter today and
so I'm gonna go ahead and turn it over
to lon
and he's going to take you through this
information today thank you Peter
okay welcome everyone so these are the
topics will be covered today we start
with the sour DV snip and then we'll go
into the new project a little frequency
aggragate or alpha project and then we
do a quick demo on the web and also on
the user API and then we'll follow a
question a QA so over 600 ml and
reference nib from 2 billion submitted
submissions and we annotate the variants
on both year C 37 38 and then over a
half a billion RS have flu frequency
data in addition to map into GST 378 we
also annotate the reference snips on the
mRNA and protein and also they also be
annotated with function consequential in
of ours clinvar clinical significance
low frequency and you can find out more
about the variant or I mean the rest nip
other attributes that we annotate and
about found out link down below okay so
the topic today is on the low frequency
so this is what we currently have in DB
snip so the name is little bit is sort
of misnomer and that DB snip contain
both common and rare variants so this
showed you a table of all the project
that currently in DB snip and to show
you the project a number subject and the
variant contribute at least one of those
projects so deviously aggregate data
both from the global survey studies
including nomad top med exact went on
genomes but we also include regional or
cohort specific studies including
the UK parent and child cohorts and also
the twin cohorts and also we include
regional or national Pacific population
and as we identified more of the studies
where every atom 2db snip and also
including the including the alpha
project I'd be including future give is
to build that is in the same scale or
one of the largest project where that
would be in DB snip okay so how do you
search for this data you can begin your
search by you going to a division
homepage the search box is on top there
are some examples provided down here you
can search by reference nip jeans you
know location for the significant and a
little frequency range to get you
started
other supported search terms are all
listed here if you click on that wing of
kids take you to the list also there's a
handout that you can download that's a
fact sheet that that can get you started
with the search and displaying the
records okay so when you search them DB
snip we had a search term what you get
back to a list of variants and the
center here and then there's some
widgets over here to help man you manage
your filters in search search queries
but then on the left here is where all
the filters are for the attribute that I
described earlier including the variant
types you can filter by ririn types
clinical significance and then also
court the blue frequency okay so once
you get narrow down your search results
on the result what is shown on the entre
display is some summary information
about the very include its bearing type
its map location the gene functional
consequence in this sensor and and also
the cleanser certificate but then it
also included the allele frequency down
here so this is the study wide little
frequency of each of these projects but
if you want to look at the sub
population let's say like
Asian inbound genome you have to go to
the reference nib page and that you just
follow this link here and go to the
photograph new page so the full reps net
page again local value again the summary
information up here but the detailed
information provided in these tabs here
so there's there's a tab for each of the
categories or information then you can
drill down information by clicking on
the individual tabs so for creakin see
if you go down if you click on it you
get this big long table that shows you
the studies and then other Apple
subpopulation in the studies and then
these samples and the low frequency so
if we zoom in on one particular region
for instance here this shows the Dom
genome studies it shows you the study
why the global frequency data and sample
size the reference allele an allele
frequency then also the subpopulations
there couple other tools on this this
table that kind of help you narrow down
to your population studied interest then
included a search filter box up here so
for instant you can just start typing at
the study name and it will sit and then
they will narrow the results down to
just to those that study and then it
shows you the result for that the other
thing we have is that the columns here's
our sortable so this allows you to sort
each any of these column underneath it's
attributes for instance if we sort by
the auto Bernalillo by the descending us
or ascending order whatever your
preference is when in this case we're
sort about descending orders and what
this shows is that this man allele is
consistently reported or most frequently
observed in Asian population across all
studies so that may give you more
confidence in terms of prevalent that's
allele for your population interest by
looking consistently the recording cost
different studies okay so you can also
download your results by clicking on
this here sent to and the different
formats the the other advantages of
using the
the entre system is that you have access
to utils API and so all the search that
you do on the web you can do that
through the API also and retrieve the
results so we have a github page that
you can go to and there's there's a demo
for an EU tales here then you can take a
look at and with other examples for how
to parse in access the DB tip data you
can also launch that demo on binder and
then to play around with it
interactively live and now I'll go over
some of the demo later yeah so here's an
example the notebook and sensing there's
codes here to access the snip Santi an
example just enter that same term and
you would normally on on the web here
and then retrieve the results the data
is also available to ftp download from
TVs the home page of DCF adjacent format
okay so that pretty much conclude that
leaves that part of this presentation so
next I will describe to you about the
alpha project MTB gap so DB gap is the
database that's a house of NCBI that
contains the results of studies that
look at the interaction of human
genotype and phenotype it contained a
large amount of data including over 1.5
million subjects and children genotypes
so DB gap actually have to Couture
access open and control and when they
was first started in 2007 the genomic
summary resolved that including p-values
and a little frequency was missing open
access however shortly after it went
live there was a publication that went
out that showed that you can identify an
individual using statistical method you
can identify an individual in a study if
you had that person genome in this Minds
anti-age to protect the participant and
also to evaluate the policy the GRS our
data was a move under controlled access
however recently this policy
been reversed so ray not so now we are
allowed to again once again share the
summary result information including low
frequency so we embarked on this project
called the allele frequency I go gate a
part of our alpha and this would be
aggregating and Lukas MTB cap and make
an available to DB snip for very
interpretation analysis so I will walk
you through how we process data so this
will give you an overview of the
processing pipeline so there's our so
age all the study that and then approve
for open access then it's QC in theory
then we then compute the ancestry of all
the subjects in those studies and then
we convert all the data into a standard
DCF format and then they get fed into
essentially a DB step build pipeline
that for normal invariant that utilizes
a couple new algorithm and variant
representation so speedy and VOCA and
you can read about about that in this
publication that just came out this
tomorrow and those algorithm we used to
normalize the Barents and then instantly
then D wants me I get the Barrington or
Martha Graham we can an aggregate
aggregate the on in division team
telling compete the low frequency make
it available to the normal TV snap
resources so that's come a challenging
with this project one of course is DB
have a large mountain with data then
Howard then and then the other one is
harmonizing the different subjects and
populations cost study and most of these
are self asserted or self-reported
population or their you have no ancestry
reported and the other challenge of
course is to normalize the variant that
they come in from become a different
format including VCF plink formats they
may came from different assembly
versions they've been called from
different pipeline and they're open its
quality so the sub one and large volcano
modern variant we've utilized the
existing DB snip and DB gap Corrections
and build pipeline and to normalize the
variance we used the program called
graph pop that is developed by
DB gap and what it does is that use the
Astra informative markers to validate
the sample ancestry removing any
duplicates and then also to assign
subject with common ancestry to
populations so I walk you through
briefly how this is done so this shows
you an example what how Grandpop
assigned the individual to a particular
populations
so what grasshop does is extensive
critic gene at a fingerprint and come of
all individual or from the genotype and
compute the genetic distances from that
for them I'm planning on a graph so what
this shows you is comparison between
what grab pop computed versus what the
self-reported population are in the
different colors individual common
ancestry are sensing grouped together
and a sample shown in these vertices and
then individual with mixed answers will
fall along the axis and shown in blue is
the 9 95% interval where those are the
one that with the common ancestry that
we assigned to publish some African
European Asian so here subject with
mixed ancestry for instant here you
there's subject as exported that I've
been reported as Hispanic but graph pop
actually identified as two separate
ancestry one is that it's a Hispanic
group with the afro-caribbean ancestry
and one Hispanic group that it has more
European ancestry so that's how we
assign the pop of the individual to
different population and there's 12
different populations that grab pop
assign them to and any individual with
mixed ancestry of not within the
interval are assigned the others so we
also using a markers too and the QC the
variance and their low frequency before
by East Studies so we compare the the
markers from the studies and then
compare them to a frequency reported by
town genome so this shows you this is a
plot of the variant allele frequency in
the study versus in town genome of
course
nice they're in a concordance oh that's
good
for the year at least for this year in
subject so this shows you this study is
didn't pass QC is because more than half
of the variants are reported where the
loo and then flipped so this when you
see this the accident inverted
essentially the children read here and
then more subtle issues as such that we
identify this here where you know this
seems to be some systematic error where
some of these variant where you
expectantly random where a sign out of
0.3 0.7 so that fell out QC also and
then meaning more subtle is like we're
down genome reported these markers some
of the markets that's heterozygous walk
but then the the DB gap study has a
marker that reported as homozygous and
typically these are from though they did
buy from microarray essay and it's
probably like that these are probe that
failed in the assay failed to detect the
higher velocity so so that's cannot see
illustrate some of the process and the
step in which we go to the QCD subjects
and also for the variants so once we
done all the QC like I said before we
take all the date the different format
convert them to it's a standard input
format and that's you've sent it going
to can DV step pipeline where they need
to get normalized and then assign RS
numbers or if they're Nava or if they
assigned to existing RS number and then
distribute to normal product pipeline
this is a build summary we did recently
of some of this it's about 50 studies
from DB gap they've been approved for
open access and this and they're in this
comprise above over 140,000 subjects and
over half a trillion genotypes and
normalize or aggregated to almost or
half a billion rest snip majority of
them are already existing to be sniffing
and then there's about 20 million that
are novel and this is a breakdown of the
populations from that build to see most
of the Europeans ninety-five percent
European there's some representation of
the other
continental populations so this is only
represent 10% of the potential 1.5
million subject into the gap so far and
we'll be adding on increasing our goal
is to increase the underrepresented
populations and the future bills and
releases and that may include no cohort
of new populations and like I said there
we included but quarterly would give
each new bill and the data for the Alpha
will be report on breast net page just
like what I've shown you already for the
existing data from other projects that
already exist in the Beast now the data
will also be accessible by an API you
can get the metadata for the population
and the studies you can also create by
position range or and also by RS numbers
and of course the debut also be
available by spoke download from the FTP
site essentially it's a standard PCF
format will after the sequence or
chromosome accession position are si de
alleles and then then the W account for
each of the populations but early
accounts okay like I've mentioned before
will the first release of the Alpha of
data will be coming out with in January
2020 so I look for that announcement
with that we'll move on to the demo
section of the webinar so first I'll
demonstrate the ant research and then
we'll go into the API so you can start
from the be snipped webpage homepage so
I'm going to go ahead and use the
example Dodie's on our help page so to
go here so I mentioned before there's
additional search term that have been
supported and then I there's some
examples shown here to some complex
curry and we can look at this for
example this kind of interesting how you
can use a little frequency to
interrogate whether a variant is suspect
or not I'll go click on this and then
we'll go ahead and explain in a bit
so typically what I like to do look at
the outliers so which I looked at for
variant where the frequency is not
detected in any of the projects or
that's rare and so here I'm queer nachi
where the frequency for zero right this
suggests that there may be assembly bias
and that there's a that the somebody may
have been incorrectly annotated that
position so that like when they compared
against assembly we'll call a variant
there but then when they go in genotype
it will fail and they will not detect on
heterozygosity or low frequency
we're instant if you look at the first
one here on th 28th the position we
poured here and allele is CG and then
you look at the blue could say all
everybody should non-detect about the
variant allele is not detectable right
but then if you look at the h-e-bs here
what we report are both on dear sister
and 738 so it does it year 38 for this
one you see a see the G here and if you
look at the older version grch37 you see
the little band flip key to see so then
if you go on and tear get even further
you can go look at the snip webpage do
you see there's no evidence what that
we're in some real that's whether that
Barents an artifact are just real again
so if you look here here's your 37 38
see he's a little bit flip but then if
you go down a frequency and then you
can't also react to see the evidence for
this about the are using the sequence
view below by adding looking at the
alignment track 40 grch37 38 so you go
to configure tracks and then you go to
sequence if you scroll all the way down
there's we have alignment for all
between grch38 and all the different
other alternate assemblies and older
version of the TRC assembly so if you go
all the way down this year's 37 the line
we teacher sees to center date here
we'll go ahead and add that there you
can see there's a mishmash that occurred
there teacher sympathy okay so this is
an example how you can using a little
frequency that's how
not in normal use case but it's kind of
interesting to then and now back to
we have tutorial how to access the data
but usually util on github so you click
on one to get out there this cup on
Jupiter notebook you can look at there's
one that we just recently developed for
however to query and parsley a little
frequency called math graph here and now
you can launch this and run an
interactive live by clipping this planet
and these are links I already had
launched one here so it's right here so
I'll just walk you through so what this
does so DB snip is part of the entre
system that allowed you to search across
not just DB snip but other database and
Link and link all the information
together so in this example what it does
is search for the gene of interest in
gene database and then they use that
information to search DB the gene to
search DB snip and then to extract the
frequency data so so these are the codes
so here we're searching for certainly
gene database first we searching for all
ACMG genes and then so what it does are
the farms that there are 60 genes that's
here so this is just some simple widget
that we developed just to demonstrate
the search and then from there and it it
then search for each of the gene it
searched you can iterate to and search
for the variant in DB snips are the
search for that starts here they found
that there are 832 snips in the this
gene here this active T P 57 I'm not
sure why the widget then show up let me
try to run it again I'm gonna have to
restart it and timeout
ky that spin abacus to explain the codes
anyway so this allowed you to search
across multiple databases and integrate
the data but so essentially what it does
is certain TV snip it grab the each of
our RS then Union the plot for instance
the one RS here the little frequency no
okay I was still running up anyway I
guess we can move through the Q&A while
there's a spinning up and I can just go
back to later you have any question on
that so if anybody has any questions
this is Peter Cooper again go ahead and
type them in the pot if you have
anything to ask right now we don't have
any questions at the moment blah and you
want to show that other slide and we can
just point out some other URLs that they
can go to if they want to in there so
just go to the last slide just this last
slide has a number of URLs that you can
go visit to find out more information
the first two are variations services
and the speedy notation are useful if
you want understand all the various API
things that we were talking about was
talking about today just to remind
everybody that we have a blog called
NCBI insights that's where you can go to
find out the latest information about
NCBI services and databases and so we
post articles up there several times a
week there's also a learn page that you
can go to to find documentation and
things like that we have a very nice set
of fact sheets that are PDFs that are on
the FTP site these are the handouts that
we give out of conferences and they'll
take you through particular resource and
show you how to do things and we have a
YouTube channel and that's where this
webinar is going to be very soon and if
you want to go there there's a nice
playlist of webinars you can take a look
at plus some other tutorials ok long we
do have one question is there a way to
check the allele mismatch grch38 versus
grch37 in the DB snip build 1:53 the
download a VCF file
yeah the only way you could do that I
guess you compared the the annotation on
GS 37 38 we did have a list if you go to
dbgap side we have it in archive the
list of leave of the variant that was
the mismatch between zero six or seven
38 if you go to ftp download there's in
the pre build 152 so the human it
doesn't matter everything yeah 51
there's no issues yeah so here's a one
or a report all the varying we're at 37
today orientations are flipped so that
should not change too much between the
last couple builds here's a kind of a
general question is the rate of
discovery of new novel snips declining
or accelerating the number of these
declining I think we were probably
somewhere near the threshold right now
but since all that common bear has been
found with all the novel variants
essentially that's the comp the rare
variants and it really kind of depends
on the study size right though the
larger the study site the more rare the
parent detect so hard to say but I if I
had the guesses probably turn a plateau
off like the rate is started decreasing
thanks one I think you sort of addressed
this but I'll just I'll read the
question anyway can we explore unique
variants those are individual specific
snips I'm not sure what you mean by
unique you mean like the one specific
for a population it's gonna be hard I
mean you probably assuming you could I
mean if you look at the audio count if
it's like one or two is probably only
coming from one or two individuals right
so those are the rare variants so we
could probably try to see if you go to
Lake so if you're certain DB snip to go
something like research for
really really really and we're gonna go
ahead and just change this from zero to
let's say less than point O so this is
one out of 10,000 family let's see we'll
find any yeah it's not many but there
are a few there so Oh actually we should
give it a zero let's just try that sucks
you just have to search for the really
real really rare variants and those who
are probably like if they're little
count is like in the twos or ones as
probably because it's only come for one
or two individuals and someone that's a
question but really I think they're just
making a point that a snip reported in
one individual is probably likely to be
an artifact rather than a true their
which is what you were showing earlier
when you were doing the zero a frequency
example okay I don't see any more
questions did you ever get this to run
okay let's do that actually you can
probably run this on other services like
download the notebook and when I'm on
zero or even Google which is probably
faster but it's not yeah I think that
all the codes is there for you to play
around with the it was supposed to since
he played out the little frequency very
variant and they're supposed to be a
drop-down menu that you can select which
where any one of the to plot for and and
it it's supposed to dynamically you can
change the query and then play around
with it but anyway yeah I'll go one last
one this will be the last question for
today so they want to find a way to
explore snips that overlap with multiple
regulatory sites for example from encode
or transcription binding sites and
essentially you'd have to look at the
annotation on the genome to find out
where those were I think but very good
question so we are we do plan on adding
the regulatory regions annotations to DB
snip power coming out this summer so
then it'll be just another attribute
that you can just filter over so it
would be just another functional
consequence that you see in DB step now
so for instance let's see so it will
have I don't think regular just like you
know part of the year there'll be a list
here that will show you all the
regulatory regions in Hanser silencer
and so on like that
and then we based on refseq annotations
a refseq ot have a project to annotate
the regulatory region so that would be
including DB step hopefully later this
summer okay thanks everybody for coming
and thank you lon and and I'll go ahead
and in the webinar now thank you all for
coming